>> Tucker: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MUCH.
SENATOR KRISTIAN GILLIBRAND HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT SHE IS DROPPING
OUT OF THE     THE PRESIDENTIALR
OUT OF THE     THE PRESIDENTIALC
OUT OF THE     THE PRESIDENTIAL.
>> AFTER EIGHT INCREDIBLE MONTHS
I AM ENDING MY PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW THIS ISN'T THE RESULT WE
WANTED.
TO KNOW HOW TO BEST SERVE YOUR
COMMUNITY AND COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE I CAN BEST SERVED BY
HELPING US DOMINIC UNITAS TO
BEACH DONALD TRUMP IN 2020.
>> Tucker: SHE WAS LOOKING
BACK AT PERHAPS THE WORST
CANDIDATE EVER TO RUN IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
SHE, IN FACT, REPRESENTED THE
WORST TRENDS OF THE MODERN LEFT
ALL IN ONE PACKAGE.
FOR STARTERS, SHE'S A PHONY.
AS A CONGRESSWOMAN IN NEW YORK,
SHE SUPPORTED GUN RIGHTS.
SHE SAID SHE WANTED TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
THEN, ALMOST IMMEDIATELY AFTER
BEING HANDED HILLARY CLINTON'S
SEAT, SHE EMERGED FAR TO THE
LEFT ON JUST ABOUT EVERY ISSUE.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT.
BECAUSE SHE CARED ONLY ABOUT
POWER, SHE WAS HAPPY TO BE
FRIENDS WITH BILL CLINTON AND
HILLARY.
BUT THEN LATER, WHEN IT WAS
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT, SHE
DENOUNCED OF THEM, BUT ONLY ONE
SHE WAS CERTAIN THEY WANT TO BE
USEFUL ANYMORE.
THERE WAS NO PROOF AL FRANKEN
HAD DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
IT WAS THAT UNFAIR.
BUT THAT'S KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IN
A NUTSHELL.
SHE IS HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT YOUR FEELINGS AND YOUR
PRIVILEGE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE FIRST THING I'M GOING TO
DO WHEN I'M PRESIDENT IS I AM
GOING TO CLOROX THE OVAL OFFICE.
WE NEED TO PASS A GREEN NEW
DEAL.
THIS SHOULD BE.
IF YOU DON'T TAKE CLIMATE CHANGE
SERIOUSLY, YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE WORLD, THE COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE.
AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I WANTED TO USE
THE DETENTION SYSTEM AT ALL.
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELI
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELH
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELO
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELT
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELK
WE WOULD DELIGHT         BE DELE
PEOPLE.
IF YOUR SON IS 15 YEARS OLD AND
SMOKES POT, HE SMOKES POT JUST
AS MUCH AS A BLACK BOY IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD AND A LATINO BOY IN
AMERICA.
THE BLACK AND BROWN BOY IS FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE ARRESTE
ARRESTED.
YOUR SON WILL MOST LIKELY NOT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT, BECAUSE
HE IS WHITE.
>> Tucker: SELF-RIGHTEOUS,
DUMB.
THE LAST CLIP SHOWS WHAT
GILLIBRAND STANDS APART.
THAT WAS GILLIBRAND, THE
UNITED STATES SENATOR, LECTURING
A WOMAN IN YOUNGSTOWN, OHIO.
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO
YOUNGSTOWN, OHIO?
SHE WAS SAYING THAT NO MATTER
HOW MUCH WASHINGTON ABANDONS
HER, THAT WOMAN SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HER WHITE PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IN ONE
CLIP.
REALLY, THE WORST CANDIDATE
EVER.
GOOD RIDDANCE, CHRISTIAN
CHILDREN.
I SYMPATHIZE WITH CANDIDATES
WHEN THEY GET OUT.
BUT WITH CHRISTIAN WITH
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IT CAN'T COME
A MOMENT TOO SOON.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYONE CRUELER,
NASTIER, MORE SELF-CENTERED,
DUMB HER CAN YOU?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, MIRROR de BLASIO.
SHE IS A COMPLETE HYPOCRITE, AS
YOU SAID.
SHE WAS A BLUE DOG DEMOCRAT.
SHE GOT HIGH RATINGS FROM THE
NRA.
AND THEN, WHEN SHE BECAME
SENATOR, SHE SAID THAT SHE WAS
EMBARRASSED OF HER 98% WHITE
HOME DISTRICT.
SHE WAS GLAD TO EMBRACE THE WOKE
PHILOSOPHY OF THE NEW LEFT.
BUT REMEMBER, HER SENATORIAL
SEAT WAS ESSENTIALLY
ORCHESTRATED BY HER FORMER
REPUBLICAN SENATOR ALDO     .
SO, SHE WILL VERY MUCH STAY AND
OPPORTUNIST.
SHE DROPPED F-BOMBS EVERY
10 MINUTES.
YEAH.
SHE'S PRETTY EGREGIOUS, I WOULD
SAY.
>> Tucker: I GUESS, WHAT
BOTHERS ME IS THAT WASHINGTON IS
FULL OF PHONY PEOPLE.
THAT'S POLITICS.
THERE ARE SOME FALSENESS.
RIGHT?
THERE'S FALSENESS IN TELEVISION
TOO.
SHE'S MEAN.
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T LIKE ABOUT
HER.
SHE SCROLLED.
TO LECTURE THAT WOMAN IN
YOUNGSTOWN, OHIO, OF ALL PLACES
ABOUT HER PRIVILEGE.
THE WAY SHE TREATED AL FRANKEN,
WHO I DON'T LIKE, I DON'T AGREE
WITH.
I DON'T LIKE AL FRANKEN AT ALL.
SHE WAS SO MEAN TO HIM.
>> Seth: SHE SAID SHE WOULD BE
THE EMISSARY FOR WHITE WOMEN.
SHE WAS GOING TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
WHY THEIR SONS WERE SPARED
POLICE BRUTALITY BECAUSE OF
THEIR WHITE PRIVILEGE.
SO, ESSENTIALLY SHE CAMPAIGNED
SAYING, ELECT ME, AND I'LL MAKE
SURE YOUR SONS GET SHOT.
>> Tucker: WAS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE, AND
A LARGE GROUP OF VOTERS, WAS
ANYBODY EVER FOR THIS CANDIDACY?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
HER STAFF WAS EVEN EMBARRASSED
THAT SHE WAS KEEPING THIS UP.
I HAVE TO SAY, I DID NOT THINK
THAT SHE WOULD DROP OUT BEFORE
MAYOR de BLASIO.
IT FELT LIKE SHE HAD MORE OF A
CLAIM, OR MORE OF A PASS.
I GUESS, REALITY INTRUDED.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I MEAN, I THINK, HERE HAVE BEEN
BEATING UP ON HER.
I DO THINK SHE'S SHARPER THAN
MAYOR de BLASIO.
YOU CAN STAY FOREVER IN THE
SENATE, EVEN IF YOUR
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND CUSTOMER
>> Seth: PEOPLE SAY THAT SHE
COULD BE SUSCEPTIBLE FROM A
CHALLENGE FROM ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
THAT MAY BE IN THE CARDS FOR
HER.